would you ever be willing to stay on a
couch for $10 it depends if the cab just
come in I don't think I'm worth now no I
mean the income is a huge help on
average we take half off our rent a
month in New York City there's a lot
wrong with it because people have spent
their entire lives here I don't feel
like they should have to pick up and
move just because Airbnb wants to come
in and make millions of dollars in New
York City the average hotel room costs
almost three hundred dollars per night
which explains the growing popularity of
a new way to stay over in the Big Apple
increasingly tourists are paying to
sleep on someone's couch or guest bed
while they're in town services like flip
key rumor amyl and Airbnb connects local
residents that want to pick up some
extra cash without a towners you want to
save on their visits it's part of the
sharing economy a growing sector in
which individuals directly trade goods
and services of all sorts from renting a
stranger's color I just listed on the
relay rides marketplace - getting a
random person to help with chores you'll
get a text or an email letting you know
that your task is underway Airbnb which
is the most popular service connecting
travelers with a place to stay is an
international phenomenon with
accommodations in 192 countries
travelers can stay in an igloo in
Greenland a tepee in Denmark or a
treehouse above San Francisco Bay
Nannan Rob are both actors and musicians
and they live together in a one-bedroom
on Manhattan's Upper West Side the costs
twenty two fifty per month they rent out
their couch almost every night for $65
we probably have about five requests per
week Wow yeah we have an I squeeze foot
massager where people can rest their
tired feet on the end of the long day
people come to New York and don't
realize how much walking they're gonna
be doing it oh that's a nice amenity for
them I'm an actor so basically
unemployed is what I'm used to so that's
been helpful but we've definitely had
some cool people ambien babe has seen
its global presence more than double in
just this past year which means that
more than ever before people all over
the world are able to visit places like
New York City when otherwise they might
not have been able to afford to you know
this place is ten dollars is that
something that would interest you oh
yeah but the photo doesn't really look
that attractive to be honest what about
something like this yeah that's more
like it
yeah that is we're saying a Tamarian
monkey that's a really nice hotel that's
good how many is it expensive there hey
it's quite pricier but would you ever
consider staying in someone's apartment
yeah I don't think I'm worth now would
you rather consider something like that
yeah but local governments are trying to
either ban Airbnb or regulate it so much
that it becomes almost impossible to
participate bizarrely Portland Oregon
prohibits Airbnb in all residential
areas of the city but allows it in
industrial areas where permanent
residents aren't allowed to live just as
long as there's off street parking
available and a six foot paid sidewalk
between the building and the street
Austin Texas allows residents to become
Airbnb hosts just as long as they
undergo a home inspection purchased a
$295 permit and live in a neighborhood
that hasn't already reached its quota
instructions for like how to operate the
remotes and everything is we have three
remotes so it gets it can get a little
confusing New York City allows hosts
like Lauren and Rob to operate just as
long as they're at home while they gets
to staying there and as long as the
guest has open access to every room in
their apartment including their bedroom
we have this curtain that we can
it up so they separated but more than
half of the listings for New York City
don't meet these criteria
that's because Airbnb has collided
head-on with one of the distinguishing
facets of New York living rent control
sick of getting screwed landlords who
own rent-controlled apartments are
foregoing the residential market and
advertising their Apartments on Airbnb
as hotel rooms which allows them to earn
much more money no other city in the
country has laws like we do here which
is really to protect tenants and to
provide affordable housing
Marty Whiteman is a tenant advocacy
lawyer who worked with the state
legislature in the passage of a 2011 law
that made it easier for the city to
crack down on this practice if landlords
want to rent through Airbnb and make
more money what would be wrong with that
I mean I don't think that there's
anything wrong with that but in New York
City there's a lot wrong with it because
the laws on the books are make that
illegal Whiteman says that when
landlords rent their apartments to
tourists for short term stays it serves
as a way of driving out rent control
tenants who live in their buildings you
have these tourists who are coming to
the city and they're there on vacation
right so they're partying they're up
late at night and sometimes people just
can't take it anymore and they very well
may just leave their their homes because
of all that do you think that would be a
problem that you know people can't
afford to live here so they simply find
a place where they can't afford to live
maybe they have a job here you know they
have they're making a living here why
should they be pushed to another state
just because again Airbnb wants to come
in and make millions of dollars now
relying on the government to keep rental
prices as usually cheap isn't the only
way people of limited means can afford
to stay in that hand I mean the income
is a huge help on average we take half
our rent and so you know it just takes
it takes the worry of money off only if
landlords tenants and tourists are
allowed to work out amongst themselves
the best way to make use of limited
space or cities like New York become
more affordable to live in or stay in
and services like Airbnb go a long way
towards making that possible your recent
TV I'm Leonie Bravo
you